it looks very tempting because you're  not only getting b5 in you're also  getting c4 and wow what just happened  c5 bishop takes e6 knight e6 and magnus  it looks like he  overlooks that  he must have overlooked  it magnus is having a bit of a  blunderfest right now look at him he's  really fed up with himself  there you go oh my god the frustration  we are heading for a playoff  there we go you can see it  c5 wow that was a tactics blunder  strategically  too tempting  as soon as magnus played it i went yeah  of course we love that move  yeah  why not of course we want to support the  night  instant mistake  after after so many games and against in  this